people let me tell you a story of an
unbelievable show called Teen Titans it
had unbelievable animation wonderful
drama exquisite comedy it was a
masterpiece
but then that was all destroyed when
they came across this abomination that
they seemed to tell us what's called
Titans go T Titans go was this attempt
at comedy this usage of fart jokes and
pee pee humor that they dare say was
Teen Titans it was not it was not for
what they did
fill a viewer they went back in time and
took all our beloved Teen Titan episodes
and they destroyed them yes so now we
can't destroy this evil Teen Titans go
because that's all we have of Teen
Titans anymore because they destroyed
the original Teen Titans episodes this
is what they did we can't watch them
anymore
we can't team x is dead so now you
understand the hatred that us Teen
Titans go haters have for Teen Titans go
them now you understand some say
we're getting too excited too angry at
something that is clearly meant for
babies no I say no Teen Titans go is
worse than Satan Teen Titans go broke
into my house shot my dog and I tried to
get revenge on them ala John wick style
no they say hello maybe I'm in fear I
don't care that's what Teen Titans go
does it makes you stupider I don't have
my beloved show anymore my beloved dog
anymore
all that's taken away from me because of
Teen Titans go I hope you understand now
I hope you understand I hate okay so I'm
not a big fan of Teen Titans go it's
just not my thing the only reason I know
what it is is because whenever I go to a
con there's really nothing on in the
morning anymore and like I'll sir turn
on the TV when getting ready brushing my
teeth get my clothes on and stuff and
like Teen Titans go is the only thing on
so I'm like okay I'll hit that on this
background noise and it's like it's not
very funny it doesn't make me laugh but
it's it's just harmless Dom
entertainment so I'm like okay and I
seen the original Teen Titans I liked it
I never got super into it sort of the
style of that anime comedy style heads
getting really big and the mouths going
like this and the big sweat beat that
that's just not my thing but I I get I
know it's a legit style and that it
takes a lot effort and and there should
be a lot of respect given to it and
there is you know that show was a huge
hit still is a huge huge following and
the drama is very good the animation is
very good the characters are wonderful I
I get all of that it Justin grabbed me
like saved avatar Batman the Animated
Series or whatever but I know it's good
and I know it enough to know the general
characters
so when team Titan go came out I'm like
okay let's it's very obvious what this
is that this is you know it's something
for little little kids this is nothing
but that comedy where their heads got
really big in their mouths are really
big it's just the dumb throwaway jokes
and it's like okay whatever we still got
the original Teen Titans show but people
just exploded with the hatred on this
and it's it's just clearly not Teen
Titans uh and I can understand that
liking it like I said I don't get that
much into it but like the die-hard hate
that people have for this is very
strange but I guess on the other hand
like you could argue that like they
could be doing more of like the Teen
Titans show
instead they're doing this so people are
angry at bad I mean I get that argument
um but to me is kind of like being angry
at Muppet Babies it's kind of like well
yeah you kinda know that going in it's
called Teen Titans go it's like calling
a show Batman Wow and expecting a
serious show it's a you kinda you should
know what you're gonna get um with that
said the the few episodes I've seen
heaven made me laugh but they're it's
harmless it's like having spongebob on
in the background like it's not super
funny or anything but it's like okay
it's colorful it's energized there's a
lot stuff thrown at you very fast and
it's for me it's not quite annoying you
know I'm like okay this is just weird
enough that I don't change the channel
when nothing else is on take that for
what it's worth so now we have this
movie we have this Teen Titans go movie
and if you like the show you're gonna
like the movie if you don't like the
show it's you know you'll get a few
laughs because I got not only some
laughs out of this but a couple scenes
were like I laughed hard at some of
these jokes some of these jokes are just
ridiculously funny and super clever and
let you kind of even one or two of them
you got to really think about for a
minute and you got a really it kind of
works on different levels uh and I love
that but there's got a ton of them uh
that the basic premise of the movie is
that Robin wants his own movie uh which
again is kind of funny Batman gets his
own movie a lot of DC characters getting
their own movies so why doesn't he have
his own movie and of course he is giving
his own movie and I like many people I'm
sure who saw this film were very
disappointed they did not have the
trailer for titans before Teen Titans go
guys I would love to see all the
children at the screening I was at you
know repeat back to their parents
Batman
I just think that would go over
incredibly this is really weird
uh-oh of all the DC franchises to like
yeah we're gonna drop the f-bomb in this
one we're gonna go like the darkest and
grittiest out of all of them Teen Titans
that's the one you do it with you so
I'll say that that preview really made
me laugh
why is right even like I don't know what
to do just so why can you help me King
like Raven was the badass wasn't she
wasn't she the one that like the only
reason Robin was the leader was because
he had some emotional connection to
humanity she was just pure Killam now
ask questions never you know like no
emotion no nothing just like wipe them
out like ID okay I'm get really
sidetracked but that that truth there
was really up so anyway we have
the exact opposite of that Teen Titans
go where Robin wants his own movie is
trying to go to these stupid lengths to
get his own movie he's trying to create
this arch-nemesis and the team are is
supporting him and doing this and they
do really crazy things like try to make
it so that there's no other superhero so
they go back in time and change the
origins of these superheroes like
telling Batman's parents not to go down
Crime Alley like it's called Crime Alley
but why don't you go down the happy
rainbows out okay we'll go down there uh
so seems like that are very funny uh but
at the same time they're trying to
defeat this villain and he kind of very
obviously has this secret plan going on
but this this is not a story based movie
this is a film that you watch mainly for
dumb jokes I really argue like 70% of
them are throwaway jokes like you know
just a joke on The Simpsons they would
use it's like okay well we I don't know
what else to put there let's just put
that and that might work um you know
it's mostly those types of jokes but
it's also very bright very colorful they
throw them a lot at you they don't
really take long pause
is to be like you know yeah let that
joke sink in it's really funny right
like it's not obnoxious like that there
are a few annoying moments there's one
really annoying one where the same
segment of--can about where they go back
in time to to try and stop the origins
of these super heroes happening the
Superman one like they play this song
and just everything about it is very
annoying
it's just cameras going like this
ragging like this and like everything's
kind of shaken the music's really
obnoxious so it's there's one or two
moments like that
but for the most part like the speed and
the energy and the colors especially
colors in this are wonderful it's a
color wise it's a nice movie to see on
the big screen I wouldn't say it's it's
too much else visually like it's not
unappealing to look at but it's it's not
something where it's I crush out there
and see it it's pretty much like a Teen
Titans go episode with a bigger budget
and yeah like I said there's about I say
about thirty percent of this movie that
really legitimately made me laugh hard
and they're sort of spread out
I'll have them have to do with like
movie stuff anytime they're on like a
movie set or they're going to a movie
premiere or something like that like
sort of the joke's on the DC Universe
the DC films filmmaking in general and
stuff like that the in jokes are all
very very funny but I realize watching
this kind of what the problem is with
Teen Titans go and why it doesn't quite
work and why I'd argue this film it
doesn't quite work you know it's fine
for little kids and even older kid I can
see kids laughing this cuz there's
nothing but jokes but the reason it
didn't connect with me is that these are
not character based jokes these are
jokes based on kind of an awareness of
the environment and key culture and
surprise humor and and kind of awkward
humor and weird surreal humor and that's
fine but the Teen Titans were very
character-based and I think that's why
I the original show got such a following
because they could do the drama very
well and they could do the comedy very
well and they worked because they were
very well defined characters and they
were made for that setting for this you
know kind of comic book dramatic but
also funny goofy set up you know it kind
of like Avatar kind of it you know where
they can do really really heavy drama
but they can also do very very goofy
comedy uh again hence that I think that
very bighead anime style but Teen Titans
go he's trying to take those same
characters and only do the comedy and
the comedy in the show and in this movie
is very much run in Stimpy comedy and
even Ren Stimpy granted they do have
distinct characters but it's very
surreal it's very goofy it's meant to be
like isn't it funny how weird we're
doing this you know the presentation is
where a lot of comedy comes from and but
even Ren Stimpy are dumb characters you
have one who's a jerk but is dumb and
then one who's really naive and idiotic
you know and super dumb you know that
that's sort of what they work off of as
this very surreal world these characters
originally were not that and they're not
really that here they kind of you know
go back and forth between like you know
a star fire well her only characteristic
seems to be putting the in every other
word you know and being happy and you
know a raven seems to be just looking a
little miserable but still being as
goofy and silly like there's one scene
where it's like they're all looking dumb
and she has like a drool
drop coming down and stuff and it's like
but that's that's not the character you
know that that's not what was set up
that's not for me with Jojo that's not
even really this show and then the
others are pretty much just catchphrases
so it's one of those things where it's
like any humor around the characters
really doesn't work it's not awful it
just it doesn't hit but there's still
30% of jokes that I think are really
super funny like Oh Robin is watching
and he's waiting
for his trailer to come up you know a
movie about him cuz there's a Batman
trailer and the movie is just called
Batman again
that's great and then like it shows a
big R and it's like you won't believe
the next Batman sidekick who's getting
his own moving the are backs out as the
middle letter of Alfred Alfred is
getting his own movie and then it keeps
going from there you know I meant the
car the car is getting his own movie
like stuff like that is really funny and
even the origin story bit the when they
find out giving rid of all those
superheroes doesn't work they go back in
time to put all the origins back and
when they come across Batman's parents
they not only set them going towards
Crime Alley but they give the mother of
pearl necklace life it's dark that's
ridiculously dark and like that is
really funny and there's several moments
where I laughs super hard at jokes like
that
but there's not many and again I think
the major fault is that they're not
really character base it's just sort of
what's so real weird stuff can we do in
kind of what in jokes can we work in and
a good chunk of the end jokes work fixes
things we can do in this and when he
realized it's DC he's like oh I got to
get out of here and he runs away but
then he comes back saying I don't care I
just love making cameo and see it's
little things like that are legit really
funny but nothing around the characters
are very funny so I feel like where
other you know something like uh the
Adam West Batman you know I very much
kind of compare this to them a respects
in terms of how you're supposed to look
at and what I think they're going for
the atom was Batman still had legit
characters you know Adam West was a
definite character and you know the
Joker and Riddler they all had these
very distinct identities to them even
though they were in this ridiculous
world uh and I don't get that from Teen
Titans go I get surreal goofy in jokes
and there's a lot of people that like
that I can't act like I don't understand
why
you know it's like I said there
sometimes I laughed really hard at this
uh but I also don't hate it like the you
know like the Teen Titan go haters
really really hated it's easy to make
jokes about it's easy to kind of poke
fun at it and be like yeah you know Teen
Titans like I've done that before but I
never quite got on like the hate hate
train for it but me that's because I
never quite got on to the love love tray
of the original either but but it is
good and I acknowledge that you know the
originals should be looked at and you
know it has great character arcs and
stories and great drama and some good
comedy like I say it just never quite
grabbed me but I acknowledge it's a
super good show Teen Titans go is a fun
little waste of time and if you watch it
for a few minutes and it doesn't grab
you it's that's all it's gonna be so if
you're not sucked in by it I get it if
you love it if you love these kind of
jokes I get that too
so that's pretty much how the movie
works if you enjoy the show you'll like
the movie if you hate it with a passion
this isn't gonna sway you but I'm
willing to bet you'll get a couple
laughs um there is one after credits
sequence it's in the middle the credits
but that's kind of indicating that the
original Teen Titans are gonna come back
somehow I'm just betting right now it's
gonna be a crossover with Teen Titans go
and that's probably gonna piss off
people even more but but it was kind of
neat like for for a couple seconds
seeing like the original Teen Titans on
the big screen cuz I guess I guess I
can't see where people are coming from
like we never did get a Teen Titans
movie it's like that that would have
been really cool to get it would've been
really neat to see a Teen Titans movie
you know but we got Teen Titans go you
know that the little kid version it's
like never getting a puppy movie but
getting Muppet Babies movies and it's
just like well okay but you got the
Muppets they would obviously make better
movies but it is still what any
it's clearly for little kids it's not
even a little okay I shouldn't say that
like it's not necessarily for babies I
mean if if I was like 12 years old I I
probably like it I probably like the
humor if I got older I don't know how
well it would hold up but but I I feel
like this is a movie where years from
now like people are gonna look back and
remember it when they were a kid and
kind of quote a lot of things from it or
sort of the dumb little songs that they
do and stuff like that so this this is a
totally fine kids movie um and for
adults that there's a couple jokes that
really work in a really clever some
might even piss off a few parents
literally the last joke is Rob and
turning to the camera and saying kids
ask your parents where babies come from
like that's the last joke and I'm just
like man you got you're gonna piss off a
lot of folks watching this but it it's
fine for what it is like if you like
Teen Titans go I don't get into it but I
had a laugh every once in a while so I
mainly saw it because these this show
just gets such a backlash and so I'm
like okay well I might as well see the
movie the big you know the fruits of
their labor see if it's actually any
good well then it has like a really good
score on Rotten Tomatoes it's like yet
88 or 89 percent right now which is
really good um I honestly thought more
people would dislike it but it's but
it's harmless it's a harmless movie
apart from having to explain to your
kids were babies
but yeah so there it is like I said I
don't think it's going to sway anyone
that hates Teen Titans over people that
like it I think will like the movie I
think they'll like that has a little bit
of a higher budget and the animation
style is pretty similar but but they
they've upped it a bit the backgrounds
look a little nicer and there's a little
bit more motion in the animation there
they're not quite so still all the time
so yeah it's
I definitely wouldn't see it again I
probably didn't need to see it but I
wasn't going nuts watching it either
like I said there was a legit laughs
every once in a while and yeah that I
guess that's about it so um it's exactly
like watching a long episode of the show
if you like the show you like this if
you don't you're probably not gonna like
this either so that's about it and um
don't let Teen Titans kill your dog
you